[Music]
you're a person people turn to and they
need someone to stand beside them no
matter what you're someone who has
fought to be where you are and people
look up to you because you're bravery
and spirit was Fergus like that he is
now
your strong Brave and Charming of course
like Jamie you're an alcoholic sorry
you're someone who will do anything to
protect the people closest to you
charging head first into any situation
you have a big heart and you often put
the needs of others above your own oh no
there's a nice little picture of us as
well yeah it looks like that is that all
just because you picked it shake it off
and on a date yeah
[Applause]
um
well we'll be in the Next Room team I
think I think it is